according to legend it was Garth
greenhand who first led men across the
Narrow land bridge known as the arm of
Dorne no one knows why men first came to
Westeros but what is known is that they
were not welcomed as men settled into
Westeros they began killing Giants and
waging war against the children of the
forest
although gifted in magic the children
lacked the fighting skills and the
strength of men it is said that men wore
children at a much higher rate than the
older races of Westeros such as the
children and the Giants men spread
through Westeros chopping down where
with trees and more and more encroaching
on the land of the children eventually
the first men outnumbered the old races
of Westeros three-to-one and against the
first men mounted and clad in armor and
with weapons of metal the children were
no match but still the children of the
forest had power and knowledge that the
first men did not it is told that the
children gathered in their hundreds upon
the ancient and mysterious Isle of faces
there they conjured the hammer of the
waters and it unleashed its fury the
earth beneath the arm of Dorne broke
open and the sea rushed in the land rage
was swallowed into the depths of the
ocean carrying all those who dwelled
there with it
it was all however proved for not as the
first men had already settled throughout
Westeros and the children second attempt
at conjuring the hammer at the neck of
Westeros failed leaving the marshlands
what old powers were besieged on the
Isle of faces to bring about the
breaking of the world according to the
world of Ice and Fire
the children called upon their old gods
with prayer song and grisly sacrifice
and some versions of the tale a thousand
men were captured and fed to the where
woods and in other perhaps even more
terrible versions the children used the
blood of their own young as we know
sacrificed before a weirwood tree seems
to have been a tradition of the first
men it seems that dying for a weirwood
tree provides a kind of afterlife
death before a weirwood tree is no death
at all your consciousness is transferred
into the weirwood tree net you become
one with the roots of the trees one with
nature and the forest itself and all the
animals that live in and
children of the forest was the name
given to them by the first men but it is
not their true name they called
themselves those who sing the song of
Earth in the true tongue a language
which no human can speak so what does
their name mean the children called upon
the old gods with prayer grisly
sacrifice and song and many cultures and
religions in our own world songs are
used as a way of communing with higher
planes of existence a way of
transcending the physical we know that
in our story songs can be used for
ritual purposes Mary mazdoor uses songs
to conjure shadows and Drogo's tit and
later sayings to create the spell which
seems to have saved Danny from burning a
song can be a spell it seems if we look
at the actual definitions of the word
song we see that it can be defined as
the musical phrases uttered by some
birds whales and insects typically
forming a recognizable and repeated
sequence and used chiefly for
territorial defense this definition
suggests that the children view
themselves as the defenders of Earth the
key difference between mankind and the
children is that men live on the earth
and the children live with the earth the
children plant no seeds they farm no
animals they take only what they need
from the land men on the other hand
destroy forests for shelter they hunt
animals to extinction such as the
unicorns and the Lions of Westeros the
point is that the children viewed
mankind is huge offenders against nature
their territory a conflict was
inevitable when the children realized
that they were losing the war drastic
measures were required so the children
are the defenders of nature and they
also sing the songs and the spells of
Earth and the old gods stirred and
Giants awoke in the earth and all of
Westeros trembled it is said that Giants
awoke in the earth when the children
sang their songs and conjured the hammer
of the waters on the Isle of faces does
this mean literal Giants seems unlikely
to me the phrase Giants awoke from the
earth is mentioned more than once in a
Song of Ice and Fire
Sherman who blew the Horn of winter and
Wolf Giants from the earth Jon Snow 3 a
clash of kings
the Horn of Joramun is a legendary horn
created by the children it is believed
to have a power to somehow bring down
the wall
it looks like Giants waking from the
earth is a metaphor for earthquakes
what else could bring down a giant ice
wall what else could rip the arm of
Dorne into shreds and break the neck of
Westeros into pieces from what we know
of the children most of their power
stems from the weirwood trees somehow
and the power of the trees seems to be
fuelled by blood the likeness between
the sap of the trees and blood has
brought up multiple times throughout our
story it looks like that in order to
harness the power of the earth a
sacrifice must be made a sacrifice to
the trees and if the children were using
their own young as the world of Ice and
Fire suggests then this could be related
to their small numbers which dwindled
from small to almost none during the
feud with mankind did the children out
of desperation make the ultimate
sacrifice killing off their own young in
an attempt to stop mankind from claiming
the forest it seems to fit the pattern
of situational irony in the story of the
children versus men the children kill
their own young to break the world and
end up causing their numbers to dwindle
even further it's also possible that in
A Song of Ice and Fire
the children use their own young to
create the others which backfires and
leads to the long night the ones who
sing the songs of Earth are their own
undoing in this series it has been
demonstrated again and again that
sorcery is costly in a dance with
dragons Milla saundra mentions the cost
of her power it was an art and like all
arts it demanded mastery discipline
study pain that to release Boake to his
chosen ones through blessed fire in the
language of ash and cinder and twisting
flame that only a god could truly grasp
and Milla saundra had practiced her art
for years beyond count and she had paid
the price blood trickled down her thigh
blackened smoking
the fire was inside her and agony and
ecstasy filling her searing her
transforming her Milla saundra says the
fire is searing her transforming her if
she is truly using a glamour to appear
younger than she is then this seems to
suggest that she is in constant pain
from a fire within all to maintaining a
glamour marry masseur mentions the costs
of magic as well stating to Daenerys
multiple times that only death can pay
for life
beric Dondarrion has left more empty and
Hollow each time he is resurrected and
eventually he chooses willingly to die
brands power was born only when he fell
from the tower and broke his legs
Arya's power was only truly awoken when
she was blinded payment must be made a
trade of source the ones who sang the
songs of earth traded in blood the blood
of their own young and it was key in
their doom